Speaker 1: Let's go next to talking about
Texas.
We talked about in the state of Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis, his approval rating has collapsed,
as covid has, because Florida, rather, has
become a complete and total covid hell scape,
deliberately delaying death numbers to always
make it look like deaths are on the decline.
Just a wacky, wacky stuff going on in Florida.
And the good news is it's bad that Florida
is a covid health scape, but it's good when
a politician's approval rating responds to
what is going on.
And it is it is just and and justified that
Ron DeSantis, his approval rating has declined
Greg Abbott's approval rating.
The governor of Texas has also now hit an
all time low.
Texas is also having its fair share of covid
problems.
Article from Truthout outlining this.
Texas Governor Greg Abbott's approval rating
has dropped over the past months as he has
led Republicans in the state to pursue and
pass a number of restrictive and discriminatory
laws over the summer.
Polling done just before the abortion ban
in the state of Texas took effect by the Texas
Politics Project, finds that Abal Abbott's
approval approval rating went from a net,
even 44 percent approval and 44 percent disapproval
in June to a net negative in the group's most
recent poll.
Now, 41 percent of people polled approve of
the GOP governors job performance, while 50
percent disapprove.
Abbott's approval rating dropped with people
across the partizan spectrum from eight percent
to six percent among Democrats.
Not a big change there, 77 to 73 percent among
Republicans.
And the biggest drop, 41 down to 30 percent
approval among independents.
This is the lowest approval for Greg Abbott
since he took office in 2015.
The poll found a majority believe Texas is
going in the wrong direction.
Only 35 percent believe it's going in the
right direction.
Part of the reason for the declining approval
and pessimism may be due to the pandemic.
This is really an eye opener for us.
The poll found that Texans generally disapprove
of Abbott's handling of the pandemic that
is also at its lowest level.
Only thirty nine percent approval.
The Delta variant has surged across Texas.
Case rates are now flattening, but the state
has some of the highest rates for infections
and deaths and a relatively low vaccination
rate, only 48 percent.
The mask mandate ban.
Remember, some states have put in place mask
mandates.
Other states have put in place bans en masse
That's Texas that's unpopular.
And importantly, the poll was conducted before
the abortion ban went into effect.
It is quite plausible that the abortion ban
will also continue to send Greg Abbott's approval
rating further and further into the toilet.
So this is all you know, my preference would
be that Texas better handled covid, that Texas
didn't ban mask mandates, that Texas didn't
pass oppressive, restrictive abortion bills.
That would be my preference.
But if they are going to do those things,
then I think it is better for the approval
rating of the governor that's doing it to
suit, to sink and to go into the toilet.
Very often it feels as though no matter what
some of these politicians do, things just
remain split among partizan lines.
They mostly are remaining split among partizan
lines.
And what I mean by that is almost no Democrats
approve of Abbott in Texas and the decline
has only been a couple percentage points.
Most Republicans approve of Abbott and the
decline has been only a couple percentage
points.
But it's been the.
And that's where you see that 11 percent decline.
Still, it is good for the approval polling
to respond to the disastrous things that Greg
Abbott is doing.
So that's Texas.
Let's next talk about Georgia.